So I said that today we would talk about a
contested or broker, democratic national convention.
It is what it means, what the implications
are, what the math of it is.
And as we get into that, I do think it's important
to understand that the reason a contested
convention is worth discussing is that in
practice it would most likely be used for
the DNC to select an establishment centrist
candidate.
Now it's, it's interesting to know about contested
conventions no matter what and how it works.
But in practice, I don't want to hide the
context being in 2020 that it is a mechanism
which could be used to deny a progressive
the nomination and allow democratic party
insiders to select whichever their centrist
of favorite is at the time that we finally
get to the convention.
So I don't want to hide that, but I don't
feel the need to bring it up, uh, throughout
the entire story.
So I just, I want to get that out of the way.
So the way that the democratic nomination
works differently than the Republican nomination
is that to secure the nomination, you need
a majority of the delegates, meaning 50% plus
one or 1,991 1990 would be half the delegates.
You need 1991 to secure the nomination.
That's 50% plus one if nobody secures the
1990 plus one delegates from the primaries,
O w, w, which are then voted on in the first
round of the convention.
Then you have what is called a brokered or
a contested convention.
There's a second round of voting, which happens
after negotiations.
Often behind the scenes between candidates
with their delegates and something called
super delegates are allowed to vote.
Now, super delegates back in 2016 were allowed
to vote on the first round.
This is why in 2016 you often had, you know,
Bernie and Hillary at different points with
roughly the same number of pledge delegates
secured via elections via primaries, but then
you had plus superdelegates.
The vast majority had expressed support for
Hillary Clinton.
And that is why from a very early point, you
saw these numbers with a massively lopsided
lead for Hillary Clinton in 2020 as of right
now, the superdelegates can't vote on the
first round.
Super delegates are widely known to support
establishment centrist candidates.
So it is likely, it's not guaranteed, but
it's likely that if nobody gets to 1991 delegates,
adding the superdelegates for a second round
of voting would likely hand the convention
to an establishment centrist.
It's unlikely that if you allow super delegates
in, they would go overwhelmingly for Bernie
Sanders or for Elizabeth Warren.
So now it's very early, right?
So why on earth would we now be talking about
a brokered convention?
We've only had two primaries, Iowa and New
Hampshire.
That's very true.
But the primary so far combined with the polling
start to point us towards a contested or brokered
convention.
Again, unless something radically changes.
So this is about odds.
There is no way to say right now we will or
we won't have a brokered convention.
There's not even a way to say that.
We could be 80 or even 90% certain one way
or the other.
But with every passing day, the polling is
split amongst so many candidates with every
primary, where three, four, or five candidates
get some delegates with the addition of likely
delegates for Tom Stire in South Carolina
and Michael Bloomberg in some of the super
Tuesday States, the odds of a brokered convention
continue to go up.
And the really important element to understand
to all of this from a strategic perspective,
is that this is asymmetrical.
If the goal is to prevent a specific candidate
from securing the nomination, then you have
an asymmetrical situation where Bernie needs
to win on the first round.
But anybody who doesn't want Bernie merely
needs to deny Bernie nine 1,991 delegates.
I've used the football analogy before.
If you're winning by seven points, the off
fence needs a touchdown.
You only need to prevent a touchdown.
You can get them all the way down the field.
You can allow a field goal, you can do all
as long as you prevent the touchdown.
Um, you win.
And thus you have an asymmetrical situation.
It's very similar with Bernie Sanders.
Bernie must get 50% plus one of the delegates
to get the nomination because on a second
round, he is very unlikely to do it.
The DNC insiders, the establishment merely
have to prevent Bernie from getting 50% plus
one that stacks things against Bernie Sanders
mathematically.
Okay.
Case in point, look@thefivethirtyeight.com
estimates right now.
As of right now, five 38 estimates that Bernie
Sanders has a 52% chance of winning the most
delegates before the convention.
A plurality of delegates, more delegates than
any other single candidate, but only a 36%
chance of winning more than half.
This would deny Bernie the nomination while
Bernie would still have a plurality of the
delegates.
So now let's look at the math of this kind
of at the big picture level.
We will use our pool of 3,980 pledge delegates,
39 80 remember you need half of that plus
one that's 1990 plus one if the race remains
roughly the way it looks right now from the
national polls through the primaries, this
is just our first estimate.
You would expect, for example, Bernie Sanders
polling 23.6 nationally.
That would be equivalent to roughly 939 delegates.
Biden would get seven 65 Bloomberg five 65
Warren, four 94 and so on down.
Now in this scenario, Bernie gets the most
delegates a plurality, but it's not a majority
and thus he doesn't get the nomination.
Now an astute viewer will notice this is too
crude an estimate because remember that most
primaries have this 15% viability threshold.
So if you don't get 15% in a particular primary,
you don't get any delegates.
So in New Hampshire, Elizabeth Warren got
9.2% of the vote, but she didn't get 9% of
the delegates.
You got zero delegates because her share of
the vote didn't make her viable.
So over time, the voting in any one state
will consolidate.
In some States, candidates could end up with
a higher share of the delegates than their
vote total.
For example, if you look at New Hampshire,
Bernie won 25.7% of the vote, but he got 37%
of the delegates because of that viability
threshold.
Amy Klobuchar got 20% of the vote in New Hampshire,
but she got six delegates.
That's 25% of the delegates.
The non-viable candidates end up sort of subsidizing
a higher share of the delegates to the candidates
that do meet that 15% viability threshold.
So this is a crude estimate, but I think you
get the idea with every primary we can fine
tune our mathematical expectations.
In Iowa, nobody got more than 30% of the vote
and none of the delegate recipients dropped
out.
In New Hampshire.
No candidate got more than 26% of the vote
and none of the delegate recipients dropped
out or are likely to drop out anytime soon.
And remember that this is self reinforcing.
The more it looks like nobody will get to
15 per 50% of the delegates, the more other
candidates are incentivized to stay in to
see what can they bargain for when we get
to the convention.
That possibility becomes more appealing to
other candidates when it doesn't seem like
anyone's going to get 50% plus one.
This could actually get significantly more
split than it is now making a broker convention
even more likely, because remember Tom Stiers
polling like 18 in a new poll in South Carolina,
he's likely to be another delegate recipient
that would again split the vote, the delegates
further Michael Bloomberg, despite the racist
audio that our friend Ben Dickson released
is polling in the mid to high teens in Florida
and Texas, which would be another candidate
getting delegates.
So this isn't the math of how a brokered convention
even at this early stage seems to be developing
and it is asymmetrical warfare in that if
you deny Bernie the nomination, then it's
wide open for the establishment to pick whoever
they want in the second round of voting at
the convention.
So we'll of course be following it.
We'll update the math with each passing primary,
but this is conceptually why it's already
something that's
being discussed.